[Music]
I'd like in for just a few minutes to
invite you to hear a few thoughts and
ideas from the architect of the Wiis de
building mister IM Pei
I'm pay has been introduced to many of
you many times and he is a very special
person here at MIT where he graduated in
1940 he's made a number of very
important additions to our campus and
the reason the building is the latest of
those and itself an important departure
could I ask you I am to share just a few
of the ideas that you found important in
designing this building
[Applause]
the reason I'm building I used to call
it arts and media technology building
for so long now I have to learn to the
call of the right way
it's a very small building in fact it's
the smallest of all four buildings that
we in our office of design for MIT but
in many ways it is the most challenging
and for me the most interesting of the
form it is that for a number of reasons
you already heard a great deal within
the last day or two about the experiment
that we try to conduct here to bring the
architect and the artists into a
collaborative process well it's not as
easy as you think because we all like to
think that we are artists one form or
another and it's particularly difficult
for the artists who are accustomed to
work in the loft and think by themselves
and often work by their by themselves
because so much has been said about it
and a great deal has been written about
it some of it you have yet to read I
know then I will not draw on that one
very much longer I will talk about two
other challenges that we as architects
face in this particular project which I
think are unique one is has not been
mentioned enough and that is usually
when an architect receives a commission
he also received a program and a budget
and sometimes the site
in this case in the fall of 1978 we
receive none of these three so we embark
on a long process of collaboration
between client or chassé clients and
architect that last of two years that
collaboration process is as new to me as
I think for most architects we are not
accustomed to making adjustments to the
program but never receive a blank piece
of paper as a start and that process is
also a first at that time I like to
single out two names and their more
behind it oh of course
Jerry reason is always there was always
there I remember Bill Porter who was
then Dean of the School of Architecture
and planning and of course Deborah
Hoover and they had the unenviable task
of bringing together eight or nine
clients each wanting something very
special for their departments to present
their ideas to us I remember one time we
had a barn not right we change it and it
becomes a very special building special
for each department photography
holography civs computer image making
facilities and arts of course I even
remember building the design where our
roof became the most important part of
the whole structure where one could
launch inflatable balloon
from the roof so much for that two years
later we had a program we had our three
clients instead of eight but we still
had to deal with the budget and that
itself is a long journey of which Jerry
and I suffer together so therefore you
have to experiments in a very small
building that architects in this case
myself and my associates have to face
namely is really the process rather than
the product the process is very
cumbersome and they glad to have done it
but I doubt I would want to repeat it
too many times now the last challenge is
in some ways least noted but perhaps
rather obvious as you come to think of
it and that is what kind of buildings
should it be given the program given the
budget given the collaborative processes
that we had to work we also have a site
on the East Campus 160 feet square not
very large just speak enough to contain
a five-story building and that's all now
this brings to mind one thing that I
want to say here this time because it's
both very obvious and not so obvious
that architecture is not the design of a
building to enclose certain activities
which are basically functional if it
were that architecture would not be very
interesting at all this is a building
it's more than an object in space it's
an object the surrounding space or
spaces if you wish I want to give you
some earlier examples when I was a
student here for the 250 years ago I had
a dormitory loom and a fifth floor of
the Wood dormitory I don't know how many
of you know where that dormitory is it's
in a corner looking at the Earth Science
Building now when I look down at that
field back in nineteen thirty seven
thirty eight I saw a muddy field in the
winter and it's also in spring and the
activities only activities I could
remember there I was playing touch
football baseball and on May Day a
greased pole that we try to climb
between that dormitory and the Eastman
building and that's building six in
building a EE we have enormous feel
absolutely without scale and somewhat
inhuman I remember that very distinctly
and when I left MIT I left MIT with that
image I say someday something has to be
built there and little did I know that I
was fortunate enough to have a part to
play the Earth Science Building was the
first
at that time you have an open piece of
land and you have to say something to
people outside of MIT and I think inside
MIT as well there's something important
is going to happen there I'm not so sure
we were right about that but that was
the compelling need at that time the
commissioning of the big sale of Calder
came with that idea that somehow one
need to recognize that space and that
Earth Science Building is not going to
fill it it takes a lot more buildings
than that then came the chemistry then
the chemical engineering building none
of these buildings are really
architectural masterpieces they are not
intended to be they shouldn't be they
are really in our jargon background
buildings that a program is very simple
laboratories offices lecture halls and
occasionally an auditorium but they have
one very important function which is
what I would like to talk about it
principally today as one of the three
and perhaps most important challenge
they are space making devices and
objects those buildings should be look
upon as walls enclosing spaces and not
as buildings standing alone in space
most of you don't remember that far I
wish you could because the Eastman I
suppose you call the Eastman Court now
is a very different place today than the
days when I was an undergraduate here in
1937 30
30-knot now why is that important to a
university into an institution like MIT
because I think a campus is not unlike a
city or town most of the buildings in
attractive city an attractive town and
by that I don't mean Houston and Los
Angeles are noted for a certain amount
of unity in which the excitement takes
place in the streets and in the squares
MIT never had that except the Killian
Court which was so precious to us then
that we wish we could have more things
then now we have many many such spaces
but that is only the beginning because
the environment that you remember and
you leave here as idea it's not
particularly there particularly that
office I worked in or that lecture hall
that I set through many many hours
really the corridors that I walk through
at MIT endless corridors and hopefully
in the future
attractive green open spaces as well
because people do interact much more
outside their offices than in and they
usually do it chance meetings or to view
dr. weasoner talk about retracing steps
in science retail retracing steps to
search for something which is already in
the natural systems I'd like to say that
in designing a humane visual environment
one need also to retrace steps back into
history the Greek Agora's the Roman
forums were no accidents they were
planned that way for interaction of
people if we wish to improve the quality
of life of the institution of the people
who will inhabit the institution
I hope MIT will continue to give thought
to the importance of these open spaces
now I come to the reasonability what are
we doing there to improve that
particular objective
all of you remember that I'm sure what
that place was like even though you
don't remember Eastman caught that I
remember but you remember the East
Campus because the kwhitaker building is
already there it was already there when
we received the Commission but between
Ames Street and the Whitaker building we
were surrounded by only Seeley Mudd
building which is being remodeled and a
psychology building which is an old
building built I think probably during
the war so it's a piece of open space
with no character not particularly
inviting and I doubt that people were
linger there and talk they would like to
get quickly through it and go too slow
more to a faculty Club
so we have a challenge here of a
different sort different from the
Eastman Court in that here we don't have
a blank piece of paper as we had then we
already had six different buildings
surrounding our tiny little site yet to
be built on they are the dormitory on
Ames Street the Whitaker building which
is break the CV Mudd building the
psychology building the car fast in the
building which is now called TRW and
last but not least something that we
have to apologize for is the chemical
engineering building with its very sharp
problem it's impossible to build a
building there because there are six
different buildings different styles
different colors because they're
different materials and all different
geometry because Ames Street curves that
you know at that point so that the most
difficult challenge of all is not
collaborating with difficult
people or interesting people which we
enjoy but really is a very professional
problem of urban design perhaps more
difficult than architecture itself if
you distinguish these two disciplines
what do you do then your building is so
small can it make a difference if so you
have six different neighbors which one
do you want to join in the Eastman Corps
there's no problem we have limestone
building by Wells father's boss Worth
and with a few concrete buildings which
go with the limestone so therefore
there's a contextual unity there which
is easy and obvious but here's not
obvious very difficult that's why we
decided to choose a very different 7th
material it becomes idiosyncratic
whereas the other buildings that I've
done here were not we're very respectful
of the surroundings and not try to jump
it up and down say look at me because
that's not what it was call for but here
it called for something here that not so
much to say I'm different but rather by
being different
maybe that 7th building could make the
other six pull together to achieve a
certain amount of unity I wasn't sure
that we will succeed but I couldn't
think of any better way than that so
therefore that building situated as it
does at a crucial site which is really
the gateway to the East Campus and yet
had all these difficult neighbors to
contend with and no one speaks to each
other that were the same language so
might as well be a united nation so
therefore this building
took this shape form and material
because of that now I come back to the
artist architect leverage to me perhaps
the most successful aspect of their
collaboration is that this small
building because of the benefit we got
from this collaboration from among very
original minds somehow work together
achieve a certain spirit which makes the
small building seem more than it is
richer fleshless outdoor piece not
appreciated enough i think is very very
important very significant you will note
if you haven't already done so it's a
very strange pattern it has a very
strange pattern it has a clashing of two
grids why i think he should talk about
that but i think i've talked with him
before so i could say something that he
would not object because he has to
mediate between the Whitaker building
and the rest not just ours and the rest
and why not create just like we have
decided to have a seventh building why
not create a clashing grid to further
multiply the differences rather the
similarity is because he'll my
similarities are hopeless and maybe if
we are successful they all put together
and form a kind of unity which can be
very special very risky experiment but
in this case in his case I think is
succeeded Nolan's war started only
inside atrium he was not content with
that
I thank him for that I he wanted it to
come outside hence those colors and
those patents patents were ours colors
were his begin to have an effect on the
visual environment outside more than
inside
Scott burdens sculpture sculpted
furniture you may say they're not
comfortable to sit on very hard but are
they important there's no doubt
extremely beautiful
in my view they're very important
because the atrium in this building is
part of the outdoor space in we expected
as Bill Porter will remind you and John
diamond she'll carry this on that we
want students to walk through this
building and not pass by it
so therefore the atrium is part of that
outdoor experience or space making so
that it can encourage interaction in
this place as well as on the outside
then atrium might have been designed by
our firm but I tell you the best part of
it it was designed by Scott burden I
need not add anymore
I think that I hope MIT I know I'm sure
MIT well because I read very carefully
what president gray had say last Sunday
in the New York Times the importance of
bringing some balance into this
institution 75% science and engineering
is a bit much unless it can be quote
unquote humanized
with other disciplines
so therefore making up spaces as
civilized societies always do look at
Paris how many buildings in Paris are
unusual-looking they're more or less the
same same height monsaert roof
everything happened inside the only kind
of building set stands out and say look
at me as a cathedral louvre City Hall
hierarchy MIT should do the same
not every building and you must warn
your architect now curb your architect
from doing exciting things there is a
time there's a place to do exciting
buildings but there's always a need to
make civilized spaces to improve the
quality of life of the people who
inhabit this institution thank you
you